sébastien lavoie économiste en chef de
la banque laurentienne bonsoir on se
fâche râle c'était 50 points c'est
peut-être devenu prévisible que la
banque allait faire ça une fois que la
réserve fédérale avait réduit son taux
directeur est fière de 50 points de base
on avait pratiquement pas le choix des
galets un peu la base y'a aux états unis
on n'avait pas le choix pourquoi pour
pas commencé à porter une volatilité un
peu inutile au niveau de la devise par
exemple et que quelque part on prend le
risque au sérieux du virus je peux
amener vraiment l'économie dans une
profonde léthargie coûts et donc pour
mieux agir plus tôt plus tard et même
plus fort que plus faibles la wii est ce
que ça va rassurer les consommateurs les
investisseurs
les entreprises c'est sûr que le virus
ne faut pas arrêter de prendre l'ampleur
en amérique du nord dans l'hémisphère
nord et en amont ne la consomme les
consommateurs on veut pas nécessairement
aller boire plus de café fait plus de
voyage parce qu'il ya le virus c'est
juste de soutenir à ce moment si la
confiance et éviter du moins une
méfiance accrue et éviter que le coût
d'emprunt de monsieur madame tenant qui
nous écoutent augmente parce que c'est
toujours possible si le virus se
transmet un effet de propagation plus
dense l'économie que des entreprises ont
moins de revenus décide vraiment annoncé
des baisses et des réductions de
d'effectifs m permanente et c'est là que
l'engrenage devient beaucoup plus
néfastes et négatives pour tout le monde
donc il vaut mieux prendre les
précautions maintenant à part le taux
préférentiel qui baise qui donne un
effet direct de la décision de la banque
du canada aujourd'hui une baisse de tous
à la banque du canada ne pourra en effet
immédiat dans l'économie nom est le même
hier se parent la réserve fédérale le
mentionner on s'entend pas là ce que
tenons à dépenser que ce demain en
quelque sorte
mais compte tenu de la débâcle des
marchés on ne pas savoir ce que c'est
aujourd'hui qu'on en prend des gens
soient aussi le coût d'emprunt des
entreprises
ici le crédit écoutes était pas
accessible ou coûte trop cher à ce
moment là le capital fonctionne pas
comme des visuels et c'est là qu'à ce
moment là on pourra voir
un scénario je dirais beaucoup plus
sévère que celui qu'on peut avoir
maintenant comme scénario de base même
si rien de ferme nomade comme comme à ma
tante à ce stade si on se regarde que
lui aussi d'ailleurs publié cette
semaine dans le croissant ce recul
serait une manière quand même importante
ce qui va en ligne avec la décision du
club handicap est ce que ce sera ce que
c'est il suffisant est-ce qu'il faudra
aller plus loin à la réserve fédérale et
à la banque du canada
si le virus n'est pas contenue dans le
prochains mois devraient pas être
surpris que la banque du canada réduit à
nouveau son taux directeur à la mi en
vrai elle si la 60 se détériore au
niveau des marchés financiers ce que
pour telle qu'aujourd'hui mais ça peut
rapidement changer côté est pas
impossible que la réserve fédérale et
les autres banques centrales dont la
banque du canada a juste à n'importe
quel moment avant que les marchés où
vivent dans une semaine ou deux pas
attendre finalement et d'essayer de
s'ouvrir un nouveau les conditions
finition déjà les banques centrales ont
beaucoup agi quand on regarde dans
l'ensemble du monde la plupart des
banques centrales ont déjà abaissé leurs
taux d'intérêt ou ont déjà utilisé des
outils encore de la place pour agir
il ya encore de la place dans le
scénario le plus sévère faut commencer à
se poser la question à ce que les taux
pour être 0 canada et aux états unis
dans ce scénario le plus le plus
amicales sont veut bien le virus est
contenue et qu'à ce moment là on revient
sur les éléments de base comme le marché
immobilier qui avait vraiment des lampes
aux cfa ce moment leurs attaquants sont
obligés de monter les taux d'intérêt
avant la finale et 2020 en revanche une
odeur il dit la porte est ouverte mais
elle est ouverte à bien des shorts sapec
ne plus bouger à nouveau dans le
meilleur des cas espérons le mais dans
le pire des cas on peut pas atteindre un
taux directeur à zéro parce que jamais
été fermé ce que déjà été fait dans
d'autres pays
en iran la trappe et japon et l'europe
passe comment voilà et avoir détourné
gatif carrément c'est pas impossible non
plus dans les élevages des scénarios
mais espérons que toutes les mesures au
niveau de la santé ins que c'est
vraiment une action concertée également
des mesures budgétaires de relance
prochainement du côté d'ottawa tous
ensemble va mener à bon port
québec et ottawa vont présenter des
mesures
spécial comme quoi par exemple dans un
budget qui se voudrait expansionniste
mais quand il faut surtout protéger les
joueurs sont présentement infectées par
le virus
donc dans le transport le touriste est
ce que ce sera des allègements fiscaux
temporaire est ce qu on veut inciter les
gens une fois que le virus est contenu à
faire en sorte qu' il ya dépensé un peu
plus rapidement qu attendent pendant six
mois on en croit des mesures là où ce
qu'on joue sur les taux de taxation les
incitatifs sans que ce soit permanent
pour essayer de ramener une reprise un
peu plus un peu plus vigoureuse qui est
jamais évident dans des situations aussi
inhabituel que celle qu'on vit près si
le virus est contenu rapidement ce que
les taux remontent
l'économie repart prend la main avant
lui avant l'été au cours du printemps
certainement certes dans les tours de
marché de référence sur la courbe de
rendement tout à fait et on aurait une
reprise partielle des usines en chine ne
veut partout dans le monde et la
confiance des entreprises petit à petit
l'idée dé consommer retransmettrait de
la partie et jaune au maire d'ecofin
d'une 20 2021 on pourrait appliquer son
côté l'association normal mais il
enchaîna aux bases si on replace les
choses un peu nouveau du virus on va
être projet d'élection je consomme
encore l'éducation d'autres fond
d'incertitudes un peu qui fait l'année
de l'humour en quelque sorte on n'oublie
pas là mais c'est sur ce titre est une
année de croissance rompu accepterait
concernant sébastien lavoie merci merci
gérard